no like I was like don't answer the door
she's still just like I'm just gonna
tell him I'm gonna tell him he needs to
go and I'm just like yo just call the
cops why does she want to create a scene
yeah with you there honestly I feel like
she thought that she found the guy that
can like assess the situation you over
committed my friend no I did this is all
on me when she went to open the door I
closed her door and locked it in her
bedroom you're like [ __ ] Andrew [ __ ]
that [ __ ] he was like where the [ __ ] is
he at like what the [ __ ] did he know
heavy where's he at like I'm hearing
scuffling and like he hit the wall or
maybe she he tossed her or something
it's going down I even put like my foot
at the edge of the door just in case and
I saw the door like jiggle like he's
trying to come in and I was just like oh
like I was I was so terrified but why
though you're a boxer no I wasn't
thinking that bro I was thinking this
dude's gonna murder me you need to keep
hand wraps on you you're a loaded gun
with no gunpowder yeah I'm just a prop
gun he's a gun loaded with empty
promises yeah